so there's this very specific aesthetic
to the videos that I think a lot of
people don't really talk about which is
that they feel first person instead of
third person sometimes we'll do like a
setup and I'll go hey all right Vin and
Brandon we're gonna make a video with
the pixel 6A and any sort of Easter eggs
that you see in the script that you
think would work here let's build it and
we'll build a set and then we'll have
the camera like five feet away from me
and it'll look incredible like a
beautiful set you look at the frame and
you're like I look like someone is
shooting a video of me not like I am
making a video we're thinking a lot
about that feel just as much as the
things that are going into the video
itself and I think that's the reason why
it never feels like we're shooting in a
giant white concrete box it's more we've
built things inside of the box to
accomplish a different vibe